[Music]
hey what's up on today's show i talk
about how i learned the hard way
that social media is nuts i
also talked to an awesome young married
mom of two who's worried about her
husband becoming an alcoholic
and i talked to this really wonderful 52
year old man
who just got remarried to a 49 year old
virgin
and he wants to know how he can help
move the relationship forward
this is an awesome one stay tuned
hey what's up what's up good folks this
is delony welcome to the dr john delony
show
a show for you by you about you
where i talk to folks from all over the
country people are actually calling from
all over the world
about the challenges they're facing the
relationship issues
what's going on in their hearts and
their minds in their neighborhood in
their country
and how we can all walk together and
figure out how to get our life
back right so if you're new to this show
man we are so glad you're here we talk
about
everything mental health issues
relational iq issues
family parenting addiction um all of it
nothing is off limits in this show and
normally in this part of the show is
when i
will talk about something and i'm being
silly by the way something that is
annoying or that makes me laugh
or that makes my co-workers laugh and
they just walk through the hall and be
like hey you need to put this on your
show
and sometimes actually most of the time
it's poking fun at myself i happen to
think that
three-wheeled motorcycles are pretty red
and then i thought that'd be funny to
talk about i
happen to think all sorts of things are
cool
or i happen to be a guy that shows up at
a at a four-way stop and i just sit
there and wave because i think i'm being
polite and i'm actually ruining the
other person
so all these things that i think are
annoying are usually things that i do
and occasionally it's not but instead of
doing that today
we gotta we gotta talk about family
business all right
so i posted
on this internet thing by the way just
as a reminder when i took this job a
year ago
i didn't have social media because i
think it's insane i like uh interacting
with humans
and i like calling people on the
telephone and saying hey how are you
doing
but as part of this gig
i i jumped in the lake it's not a lake
it's a raging river
and so i a couple of things
i don't watch the news as a matter of
course i just don't
um it's a way i keep myself well and
whole i have friends who work in
government
i've got friends who are high
high-ranking folks in the military and
my wife watches the news and so if
things are going on that i need to know
um then they let me know or i'll reach
out and say hey is this something we
need to be concerned about and they'll
say yeah this is a pretty big deal she's
probably put gas in the car it's all
coming down man
but they probably don't ever ever say
that um
and sometimes like when there's a
weather event or there's a
major political thing going on then i'll
turn the news on and try to catch up on
what's going on
but to tell you the kind of person i am
how my house works
is when we watched the election results
come in um
i had a screen up with msnbc
and a screen with fox news and i sat
with my 10 year old and we watched the
election results come in and we
discussed how each
group was talking about which side and
which one felt like
this sounded accurate this one wasn't
and i actually walked away
impressed with everybody like wow man i
was expecting there to be this and
i didn't hear a lot of that and but
that's the kind of house we have so if
we're going to turn it on we turn it all
on
right so fast forward to
inauguration day i'm walking through the
office i'm busy that day we started
early early
filming recording all kinds of stuff and
i walked through the office
and there's a giant flat screen in my
boss's office
and it's got the inauguration i was like
that's today that's today and i stuck my
head in and i realized i missed it it
was over
and it was over
and karl rove's face was all happening
on fox news channel
carl rose's face was on there and i
thought oh i wonder what he's going to
say
and he said something to the tune and we
talked about this in a previous podcast
he said something along the lines of
that was that was a good speech joe gave
a good speech
so i went back and checked out the
speech and it was a good speech
and i walked out and i pumped my fist
actually right i pumped my fist and said
man maybe
people are gonna just clear the smoke
out of here and we all have to just
put everything down and figure this
stuff out and again i'm an optimist i
think we're gonna work together
that's the only way forward right and so
not thinking about
about any sort of thing i wouldn't know
about i posted the following on the
internets
that day because i walked away with my
with my fist pumping
like man we're gonna figure this out and
i wrote
and i quote i'm reading from my internet
phone
today we're about unity saying i'm sorry
saying i don't understand can you tell
me more saying
i'm all in for the good of all and then
here's what i went on to write
no more yelling let's solve the messes
together
i don't care what side you're on what
conspiracy theories you're obsessed with
what some internet sites you follow
today is a beautiful day for democracy
for all of us now for the hard work of
unity
repair apology science faith hospitality
understanding
and curiosity becomes very very real we
got hard work to do
don't seek to judge seek to be curious
don't seek to fight
seek to understand don't swing first
listen first
and buy somebody gas or a meal or pay
their light bill today
do something for someone else and let's
start unity off on the right foot we
need each other
that's what i wrote you would have
thought that i typed into the internet
machine let's start murdering children
effective immediately kill them all
let's do it or that i said something
along the lines of
i i don't even know i can't tell you
the vitrol that came back on this little
device
um i would talk to the liberals john for
the last four years they've leveled
heavy and vitriolic
accusations for simply supporting a
political candidate in a two-party
system
um what else did they write this is so
great man
um let's see here
oh you opened a can of worms man i know
where you're coming from
i feel the wounds run too deep and this
administration will only further
divide um
i was reading this thinking yes yes and
then i read a beautiful day for
democracy
well no well no not if you're on the
other side and believe voter fraud
occurred i'm sure that's your reference
to conspiracy theory so in essence
you're calling for unity
at the expense of someone else's beliefs
why what are you what are you talking
about um this was
this is super great um i'm gonna choose
to believe this is john saying choose
unity
and not just parroting biden so here's
what i didn't know
i didn't know that unity and kindness
were now
have been co-opted by a political party
i didn't know that
oh this is my one of my favorites i
personally think this post was over the
line for an upcoming
radio national radio personality i agree
with your message but not the manner of
enactment by the democrats
that's why many republicans what are you
talking about
so i've sold this before it i
intentionally don't tell people who i
vote for
i intentionally don't care
i have had people in my home who would
make bernie sanders go
whoa that's too far and i've had people
in my home
sleep in beds in my house that trump
would go
all right guys that's probably too far
we should probably reel that back in
everyone is welcome at my house
and this isn't a political exercise for
me it's not a theoretical
you are welcome at my home you're
welcome in my
in in one of my bedrooms you can sit at
my table and i'm going to feed you and
we're going to talk because i love you
and then we're going to go from there
and so
i need everybody i don't care what
political side you're on somebody was
like that guy's like sounds like a woke
liberal christian what is that
someone is like that guy sounds like he
is a fading
like a like a fading uh what do you call
it
conservative that guy's really a
hardcore you're all wrong
you're all wrong i would make everybody
uncomfortable at any table i sat
at and everybody at that table would be
welcome in my house
unless you're going to be ugly to my
kids unless you're going to be ugly and
disrespectful to my wife you're welcome
in my house
and here's why when you get angry and
we've talked about this before but this
is a
chemical thing when you get angry when
you get
scared literally the part of your brain
the amygdala that's
that is designed to to fire off your
fight or flight
unhooks your frontal lobe it unhooks
your ability
to critically think it unhooks your your
ability to say
huh tell me more about that here's why
10 000 years ago when you're sitting at
a cave and you're sleeping and you open
your eyes
and there's a giant bear at the front of
that cave there's a tiger next to the
bear
and next to the tiger is four lions
they're all
carnivorous buddies we just don't know
that yet but there's a couple of lions a
tiger and a bear
your brain doesn't want you to go huh i
wonder if those guys are all nice maybe
we could hug
let's pet let's pet come on everybody it
just wants you to run
run so it takes off the part of your
brain that
is it is trying to piece together new
information
to uh build consensus to think through
things it just says run
in our news stations internet blogs that
just get paid on clicks people
they don't want you to sit down and
think through it they don't want you to
read something go that sounds bananas
i'm going to call somebody they just
want you to
freak out they want to sound the alarms
inside your body
they want you to continue clicking and
clicking and clicking and they will
rabbit hole you down conspiracy theory
after conspiracy theory and good folks i
love conspiracy theories
my dad was a homicide detective growing
up i love them
and i don't believe most of them
occasionally they're true because they
happen
but most of the time they don't they're
not real
was this a contentious last year god
almighty dude
they are still building um cities with
smoke rising from what happened
was what happened at the capitol a few
weeks ago now maybe a month ago now by
the time you hear this
is that scary yeah man are people's
hearts racing
yes and that is all the more reason
why you have to know how your brain
works that if you are filled with rage
if you are filled with anger
if you can't help but comment on some
knuckleheaded podcaster's instagram page
man i'm just i'm imploring you
whatever injustice you think was done
whatever
some guy told me that biden's on china's
payroll and they're whatever you happen
to think
i'm just i'm asking you take a breath
slow down and this doesn't just apply to
politics this applies to your home
if you think your 11 year old kid is
doing something
just to make you rage take a breath just
take a breath
because he's probably not if you think
your wife did this thing
just to make she might have but probably
not
probably not and if you approach every
situation with this
internal fireball nothing gets solved
everything burns to the ground and so if
you think the last four years were ugly
and hate filled and rage filled they
were
if you think people were ugly and rage
filled and hateful
they were if you got your feelings hurt
deeply
you're one of all of us if you are
terrified about the future of the
country you're all of us
if you reward what the democrats are
going to do with some things you're all
of us if you're worried what the
republicans are going to do you're all
of us
but what i'm telling you is being full
of rage won't solve that problem
inviting people to your house especially
people who don't look like you
believe like you who have different
everything from you
invite those people over
and offer them pizza unless they're
gluten intolerant for god's sake getting
something i don't care what you get them
get some good good good wine
and then say hey let's just hang out and
you're going to learn a lot and you're
going to live longer because your heart
rate is going to slow down
your brain is going to slow down and
then you're going to start being able to
see okay this one
this is a real threat this one i'm
really worried about we need to call our
congressmen
my local church my community group we
need to really dig in on this
these not real not real
so that's my rant that's not even a rand
dude that's just my plea
that's just my plea and here's the thing
if you are somebody
who just in your soul man you're armored
up you are ready for it this may not be
the podcast for you dude
because what i'm trying to get people to
do is to breathe and slow down
and heal the the person they look in the
mirror so that
they can heal their family so that they
can be part of the healing
in their legacy so that they can be part
of the healing
in their communities and in their
country
finding somebody new to hate will solve
none of your problems
none of them it just ends up in piles
and piles of bodies
period
there is one person on planet earth
besides me that knows who i voted for
this year and that's my son
because i took him into the voting booth
with me they let me take him in this
year
and um i walked him through the whole
democratic process and i wanted him to
know that in the middle of a pandemic
this is what this is what democracy
looks like
and so i stand by my statement there was
no bombs going off on inauguration day
there was no fires raging at the capitol
on inauguration day so democracy won
we transferred power it happened we did
it civilly
and for generations and generations
thousands of years that hasn't been how
that's done so whether you liked who's
in the white house or you don't like
who's in the white house don't like how
it's done
you think everything got stolen and you
think
it happened to hand the baton over
and now we've got two choices we can
just
continue to just poison everybody hoping
that somebody else
poison ourselves hoping somebody else
dies right
or we can do whatever we can to help
whatever president
is in in order is successful so we can
all be successful together
so that's my thoughts on that um you
know what the most shocking thing is to
me
what's the most shocking thing that
person you said you're a forthcoming
radio host
yeah i mean talk about eternal optimists
talk about fake news i mean i don't
think that there is nothing more hashtag
fake news
than um i'm a upcoming national radio
broadcast host
guys i run a podcast that like seven
people and my mom listened to
and my mom does it in secret she doesn't
want her friends to know that she
listens to this
my wife i was like hey how many have you
listened to
she just turned beat red she's like i've
never ever downloaded even i don't want
that on my feet because it's weird
and i've got a couple of buddies that
just will text me every once in a while
hey dude your podcast sucks that's
pretty much all that it is man
not really it is
that hurt my feelings james but you know
what
you know what i'm gonna be kind i'm
gonna default to unity
which evidently is a politicized term
what happens if they politicize
um let's all eat like oh i see
now hmm we're just gonna start eating
yes
yes let's just eat i i is my goal in
2021 to politicize
rando words i'm gonna make it i'm gonna
do it all i can
and we're gonna have a blast like oh
you're just gonna drive your car now is
that what
i'm gonna make it it's gonna be great
all right all right let's all y'all
tired of listening to me let's go to
my good friend barbara in dallas texas
barbara thanks for hanging on there and
letting me do some housekeeping
how are you this morning um i'm doing
good dr john how are you
good good good how's dallas texas um
it's pretty good yesterday was actually
a
a good day to go out very cool warm
very cool all right so hey how's it
going what can i do how can i help
okay uh so i'm calling to ask
about how i can navigate my husband
most likely being an alcoholic i'm
getting to
yeah i'm getting to a point where i
don't want to be
in this anymore if i'm going to have to
be the adult
every single night and put our kids to
bed while he's like
junk a little too much he's not going to
sleep on the couch
so we are both 25 we're married and we
have a toddler
and a newborn and why why it hurts so
much to me
is for one obviously i love this guy
i do not want to see him go down a hole
and then two
my parents have gone through so much to
intergenerational curse of alcoholism
and obviously with that being said we
both come from families who have
or still abuse alcohol and i just really
don't want to get to a point where
i'm going to be in the hospital and i'm
going to find myself
seeing my husband with liver cirrhosis
or just something like that
and i deserve better he deserves
deserves better and our
children do too yeah i'm i'm high-fiving
you
and i'm heartbroken for you i'm hugging
you and high-fiving you at the same time
um i'm so sorry that's happening um
so walk let's walk back a little bit is
this new behavior
or has he always been the guy that had
one or two too many but he was funny
about it he was silly about it
but and now it's it's starting to wear
on you because you got little kids or
has this
come on in the last couple of years as
you've
brought toddlers home into the house um
okay so we've been together since we
were about
15 14 or 15 years old so all throughout
high school he like was very adamant
about
not drinking not doing any of that
and then after high school we had a
breakup and then he ended up
dropping out of college and in that
state that he was in of like
our breakup him leaving school i guess
he felt like
in a sense he wasn't good enough so of
course there was some sort of trauma i
guess
from that and that's whenever he started
developing had a habit
and then we got together so that was in
2015 we had broken up for a year
and so i guess he developed those in
2015-2016
and so we got back together in 2016
and uh eventually got married in 2018
and in 2018 it wasn't as bad but i could
see
there was some for lack of better words
uh demons that he brought along into our
marriage that he didn't
put down so why did you marry a guy that
you saw
with a problem um i guess
i'm i guess you can say i'm a fixer
person
like i thought us getting married and
planning our future was going to like
send a an alarm in his head like saying
oh
there's something better for me barbara
you are sweet and kind like me
i thought that the country would just
come together and look at that so look
at us
right we're such a naive optimist so
yeah um does he have alcoholism in his
family
or mental health issues or trauma his
family he's got it too
yes he his dad passed away
at a very young age his stepdad
uh i i hate to say this but i think his
that has a drinking problem
too okay um and i think uh it's
it was more of a learned behavior for
him because
his stepdad started drinking whiskey and
the next thing you know a month later
my husband's going to specs and buying a
bottle whiskey i'm just
like so so how
when you sat down and talked to him how
does that conversation go
um he thinks i'm belittling him okay
are you and that no not at all
i i've come from a family
like where my dad used to do that when i
was a very very very small child
i barely remember it and i know
that it can lead to so many other
uh bigger problems and i just don't want
him
to find himself in a big problem where
he can't sure he thinks he can't get out
of
because whenever you drink you're it's
not really you
you're being controlled by that subject
uh well sometimes and if you're an
alcoholic and you've got a problem and
you're
intoxicate all the time then yeah so so
how can i help you
i just i don't know how to help him
so the i'm gonna be totally honest with
you okay
okay um both up and down number one
you can't you can't make him do anything
you can't um weaponizing
your body weaponizing your kids
weaponizing the home and family he has
won't fix that problem
a great mighty blowout fight won't fix
that problem
he's going to have to make a decision
that he's going to have to plug
in and be the dad that those kids
desperately deserve
that he is not going to
continue a legacy it wasn't his
biological dad's fault he passed away
he's not but he's got a legacy in his
soul now of
a disconnection between a son and his
dad and
alcohol fills that for a while it
actually works that's the problem with
it it works for a while
and it helps numb that um
that forest fire in your soul for a
season right until it burns everything
around you down
um he's gonna have to learn some
behaviors and decide i'm gonna be the
kid that these
i'm gonna be the father these kids
deserve and what you're gonna have to do
is develop boundaries and be real honest
with him
and you're going to have to get a
community of people around you and he's
going to need people in his life
and there is a chance that a
a a letter that he can hear that you
write that is not
going to war with him but his compassion
letting him know that you're
that you love him and you are by him and
he's your guy and you are
in all of this but that you are losing
him
and you want him back and here's what
that's going to look like
here's here's why i like letters and i
say letters almost every show here's why
i like it
when you talk to an addict when you talk
to an angry person and they feel the
slightest bit
of you versus them every wall they have
throws up
and they don't hear you right and then
he says things like you're belittling me
you're attacking me
which honestly you might be you may not
feel like you are but
it may be you may be hearing it that way
right a letter allows him
to get defensive and get his feelings
hurt and then come back to it
and then come back to it and you get to
hold it in your hand there's something
about the tactile
it's not an email either especially it's
not a text for god's sake
but you get to hold a handwritten letter
he gets to see your
your um handwriting and there's
something about going back to it and
going back to it that it slowly can seep
through you it doesn't always work you
can throw it away you can water up and
throw in a fireplace right
um but letting him know
that you're losing him and that you have
a if he's not hurting your kids and he's
um
he's neglecting your kids let him know
man the kids miss you i miss you
and we and you both probably have some
learning to do
on how to be connected intentional um
uh unified parents oh great i use the
word unity again
there i go throwing liberal propaganda
all over my show being unified parents
right um y'all gonna have to both learn
how to do that if you come from a house
alcoholics do
you're gonna have to learn that as well
right but if you offer to do it together
he may join you he may not that doesn't
mean that you don't have to
you don't need to go learn some skills
on year round
so write him that letter and make it
heartfelt
take him out somewhere or have a place
where the kids are gone you've got a
babysitter and y'all can have a heart
conversation that's not a fight that's
something you all plan together
and that you can he can actually hear
you
and um if you can't he can't have that
then it may just be leaving that letter
for him and letting it marinate
right and then the second thing is you
gotta go start taking care of
you that means i'm gonna recommend you
go see somebody
go see a marriage counselor go see a
counselor on your own
and let them know i've got trauma in my
background that i've got to deal with i
need to learn how to be a
connected good mom no
25 year old married couple
with two little ones are gonna have
great lives right now they're just not
they're gonna be filled with no sleep
and exhaustion and people walking around
looking like they were hit by a bus
and everybody's falling asleep on the
couch all the time that's part of it
and sometimes getting a counselor that
can walk you through some of that is
is relieving right it gives you some
peace
and hopefully he will see you standing
taller
being more intentional being more
plugged in being more whole
and he's going to want to be a part of
that but all of that rests on
on a on a foundation of you can't solve
him you can't cure him you can't
um make him he's gonna have to make some
hard
hard decisions in his own soul my hope
is he's got a couple of men there in his
life
um that will be really up in his face
and that will be intentional with
holding him accountable
in a way that you can't and my hope is
that a
letter and a night together that's not a
fight that's not a war but that is a
hey we gotta come together um
he'll hear you he'll finally hear you
this is a hard one barbara and i don't
want to make it light
um my guess is you're going to have some
seasons of
rough waters ahead and don't
let any of this um
deflect you from the kind of parent and
kind of mom that your kids desperately
desperately deserve
don't let any of this reflect on you
that you have a right
to boundaries you have a right to safety
you have a right to a whole
healthy well life um and
man i hope he plugs in i want you to do
me this huge favor barbara i want you to
write him this letter i want you to
to be vulnerable and have this hard
conversation with him in a compassionate
way
in an offline way in an intentional way
and then i want you to let me know how
that goes and if he doesn't
he doesn't hear it from you tell him to
call the show and i'd love to talk to
him as well
i've talked to my fair share of 25 year
old texans who love whiskey
and who are struggling with dealing with
two young kids and a wife that loves
them
and i'd love to have that conversation
with him too but thank you so so much
for that call
all right before we go to jack i get a
lot of emails
questions about it's kind of the
the problem de jour is
uh both narcissism we've talked about
that on the show and
gas lighting right what is gaslighting
gasoline and gas lighting this gasoline
that
here's all gas lighting is it's a
it's a form of psychological warfare
when someone you love or someone you
think you love
someone who tells you they love you
makes you feel unsteady spiritually
psychologically emotionally
by getting you to doubt
and question your own heart your own
feelings your own soul
so for instance let's just say
you're a 30 year old woman married to
a guy and he comes home late five days
in a row
and he starts not letting anybody look
at his phone
you can't see my phone you can't see my
phone
and then all of a sudden your phone
calls
your phone rings with a from your friend
and she says
hey your husband was out like with some
other lady the other night
did you know that's happening and you
ask him about it you start putting well
one plus
two plus three wait a minute and you ask
him
hey you've not been coming home on time
and you've been
you know hiding your phone a lot and my
friend just said you were having dinner
with
somebody else and the response is
whoa where did these trust issues come
from
why why why don't you love me
you're crazy can you not hear yourself
you're nuts
and you say no i'm not nuts you're
coming home late
and come to mention it you were wearing
a different shirt yesterday when you
came
home then you went to work and the
response is
i you've got to get some sleep you're
crazy
if you want to go through my phone
you've got some real trust issues you
need to deal with and i
i love you and i'm married to you but
whoa
um i don't know where all this is coming
from your friend's a liar
i was having coffee with a co-worker
working through a problem
are you suddenly the jealous type i
didn't i never took you to be the
jealous type if this suddenly happened
man you may want to get your hormones
checked
that's gaslighting someone who looks at
very simple patterns of behavior
can't own up to hey you know what i was
late i'm sorry that sucks i should have
been on time i was late i'm an idiot and
i'll fix that
but instead says whoa whoa when when did
you
start being so insecure that me being
seven minutes late
was a big deal for you i don't what's
happened in your heart right it makes
you
makes you begin to question yourself so
here's here's my rule of thumb there
if somebody in your life makes you feel
small or less than
i want you to get by yourself
and write down how you are feeling and
you hear me say this all the time i'm
going to keep saying all the time i want
you to mine your feelings
for truth i feel like
i'm crazy because my husband came home
late
he said this he said this and then i
want you to get with a friend and i want
you to read it out loud to that person
someone you trust someone that you can
lean into
and they will tell you you know what
that feeling you're nuts that's not
really real and i've got guys in my life
that have done that my friend craig my
friend todd my friend john they they'll
tell me
yeah you're you're an idiot that's not
true but they'll also say
hey i hate to be the one that's gonna
call it out man but you're right
um this is a big deal and i've do that
done that for people
over the course of my life too many
times to say hey
i don't i hate to be the guy that's
telling you that but she's gonna leave
you
or i hate to be the guy that's telling
you that but um
he's struggling with a drug addiction
whatever that happens to be so
write down these thoughts write down
your feelings demand evidence from them
mine them for truth and then read it to
somebody that you trust
and then if somebody in your life is
gaslighting it's insidious
it's a form of abuse that is that is so
insidious because it makes you question
you if somebody hits you with a 2x4
you know they're psychotic right they're
evil
but if you keep questioning your own
feelings and your own thoughts and your
own
relationships it starts to make you feel
bananas
and you slowly start to drown as though
it's a giant snapping turtle just
pulling you underwater slowly
and it's insidious and it can it can
grow roots that will stay with you for
the rest of your life
cut gaslighters completely out of your
life it's a tactic it's a it's a
it's nonsense and it's evil cut them out
of your life
and get somebody to walk alongside you
while you do so that's my thoughts on
gaslighting if you got questions about
particular things i'd love to hear from
you
um give me a call and by the way i
forgot to put the number at the
beginning of the show great production
job there james for calling that one out
it's one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one
that's one eight four four six nine
three three two nine one give me a call
or go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form it goes to kelly
and we will
rendezvous on the show all right let's
go to jack in kansas city missouri
brother jack how are we doing man hey
i'm doing great dr d
i really appreciate talking to you i
appreciate you calling man how can i
help this morning
well i need to preface my question with
some serious gratitude
between you and dave and chris uh
i mean just a huge part of my
pre-marital dating life to prepare us
for the realities
and manage our expectations
for for marriage and it just means so
much to us
my wife is a huge fan of yours from day
one
so it's an honor to talk to you well she
joins my mom
as she doubles my audience so i'm
appreciative of that jack
and um before we move on can you go
ahead just real quick for me just rank
in order of importance who's the who's
the most important me dave or chris
i'm just getting done do that oh come on
i'm clear i'm really number one
so brother jack um so are you newly
married
uh yeah um a month ago uh i'm 52
and a month ago i married a 49 year old
virgin
okay so is this your first marriage it
is my second marriage second marriage
okay
and i'm assuming this is her first
marriage
exactly okay all right so you're a month
in and you are 52
so you're halfway home right and um
i don't know why i always go to talking
about death sorry about that but
hey you're living your best life at 52
you got remarried
and you married a 49 year old who's
never had sex before
right okay right i'm assuming that's why
you're calling
yeah yeah um we're having you just call
me with a retirement question man just
how do we move the 401 over whatever i
won't know how to answer that but
i can at least do as good as hogan can
right but all right so go ahead
yeah i mean this is a unique situation
yeah so uh
um i i uh i feel like
we're having some intimacy challenges
where
we've had some attempts to consummate
and with varying degrees of
of success but there's a lot of fear
of physical intimacy with her and i just
need some tools and knowledge
to kind of help because she um
basically you know was single for so
long that she just kind of
divorced herself from that physical side
of pleasure was a
foreign word i think um
so so she's kind of reintegrating
you know even that language into that
part of her life and
uh i i we knew this going in it's
not a surprise um we
we just are going to take our time with
it but i'm just
you know i'm like who are you jack
you're like the greatest guy i've ever
met
because you know what i was expecting
hey you know what i was expecting i was
expecting that you to say
what's wrong with my wife and you're not
you are asking me
hey man how can i grow how can i learn
some stuff how can i
create a safe environment brother i'm
telling you right now
if there's more jacks in the world we
don't have all this nonsense
right so you've made my heart feel good
and i
i i'm just grateful to even be able to
talk to you today
just even your patience and your
kindness is awesome so
a couple of um broad basic questions
here does your
does your wife have a history of trauma
or is does she just never find the right
person
and virginity was a was a thing she
wanted to hang on to
and then suddenly it turned into late
20s and late 30s and then suddenly she's
almost 50 and then she finds the right
guy or did she have
a history there that she really needed
to part ways with intimacy
and any sort of vulnerability there
that's a great question she had
the only trauma that really played on
her ability to
form relationships with people was you
know she
poured herself into her work after a
death in the family
and that was hugely traumatic for her
and you're right time slipped away
the opportunities i guess
i i hate to use the word dried up that's
such a horrible
term but um
life happened right and we we live in
this world where uh
if you don't if you don't you know go to
your four-year undergraduate degree
and then find somebody and you'll date
for 18 and a half months and then get
engaged and then get married
or you get your master's degree and then
you're 29 and if you don't follow the
road
right there's something wrong with you
right and so i don't and
yeah and her purity became part of her
identity because
i mean it was obviously her you know we
wanted
to do things according to god's plan and
she did her whole life
so that combined with everything else
just kind of
ended up with her where she's at so sure
so
um i guess my my meta question is
is she in interested in this does she
want to
have a great sex life with you in a
intimate marriage and a fun rambunctious
um no holds barred relationship with you
i can't speak to rambunctious but i
can't tell you that
she wants a normal life in that area
okay i'm gonna tell you
don't settle for normal okay normal's
boring
settle for rambunctious settle for two
people
that um cultivate desire in one another
and yeah so we live in this funky place
and there's several great books you can
read on
on just the evolution of marriage in
fact me and my friend rachel are gonna
have a whole event on this coming up in
the next few months um
but we've traded in the last 30 to 40
years we've traded safety
for intimacy so you meet somebody and
you're attracted to them and your heart
races and you can't just wait to make
out right
and you practice safety is he going to
show up when he says he is
is she going to return my phone call
that first time one of you gets sick and
the other one brings food by
you cultivate safety and then what
happens is
you begin to trade safety doesn't is
is butts heads with desire right
to be crass about it nobody wants to
make out with their mom or their brother
right or their or their sister that's
safe
i know that person there is no desire
there
none right but there's safety
and then as you be as you feel safe with
somebody and y'all two
are you know 50 you're halfway through
life
you all understand safety you all
understand independence you all
understand those things
what they didn't tell us in premarital
counseling what they didn't tell us
in grad school they didn't tell us this
at all and our parents
certainly didn't model this because they
didn't know is that once you
achieve safety once you have the hard
money conversations and the 401
questions and you make a will together
once you feel safety then and it usually
happens in your 30s and begins in your
40s and 50s especially
you have to practice desire you've got
to
cultivate desire as though you are
practicing safety early on in your
relationship
and it feels weird to practice desire
because that's not what romeo and juliet
told us they said we're just going to
walk into a room and be like oh my gosh
there you are
or you know jack and rose they didn't
you know jack didn't see rose on the
titanic and be like
what we need to do is to practice
intimacy nah man they were like making
out in some weird car and then they died
to get well he died
because she didn't let him on the door
like a sucker he could have fit on the
door
but here's the thing so they are
they're you got to practice it and it
feels weird to put sex on a calendar
it feels weird in your case to
be intentional about going slow and
saying hey we're going to have a
relational goal of here
and the moment she feels unsafe she gets
to call it and then we're out and we're
going to go again
and you're going to have to practice
patience and you're going to have to
practice
what i like it comes from emily nagask
i'm gonna recommend a book for you two
guys to read together
um but you're gonna have to practice
turning on
all the ons and turning off all the offs
um
intimacy especially in a marriage
relationship is
so often ecosystem related it's
environmental
right here's a good example my wife
um likes to have all of the dishes done
and the kitchen clean
before anything else happens in the
evening
and i became so insecure i started
taking that personally
and i the story i told myself was
she would rather have a clean kitchen
than hook up with this
nice piece of meat right and i don't
know if you can see me right now jack
i'm
smoking hot okay so i just i got to
where i was thinking i'm not really but
i
i that's why i do radio i got to
thinking
man i can't believe that she would trade
a clean kitchen over this
and it wasn't until we sat down and had
some hard conversations that i realized
she can't stop judging herself she can't
stop feeling
a entire culture that says if you don't
have a kitchen looks like this if you
don't have a heart that looks like this
if you don't have a period of any of
these sentences
you're not a true wife you're not a true
mom you're not a true
fill in the blank right i didn't know
all that baggage that comes along how
much it
sucks to try to navigate the world as a
working professional wife
mother all that stuff it's hard and so
dude what i decided to do is stop taking
it personal
and then i try to clean the kitchen man
if that's
if that's what it is dude i've got you
on that right
and it took us having this conversation
about what's the environment look like
what are the offs and what are the ons
the book i want you two to read this is
not a faith-based book um you mentioned
that y'all are both christians and you
have a
a christian ethic this is not a
christian book it's the best book i've
ever read when it comes to
talking about establishing establish
establishing good grief james we need a
dictionary on the show
establishing um sexual intimacy
right and so a blow by the parts that
you don't like but there is an
extraordinary discussion
and it's written for women but it's
called come as you are by emily nagoski
and um it is exceptional
when it comes to you recommend that book
before i'd recommend y'all both read it
together
and it will probably make her blush it
will probably give her freedom here's
one of the
ultimate um thesis of that book
life is too short to not have an
incredible sex life
it's just too short life is too short
to pretend that guys just have a sex
drive
and girls just have a sex drive light
those are not true either of those are
not true they're not real
and so she cuts through a lot of the
myths and then she gives you a lot of
tools for how couples can
grow together and learn together and how
women especially can
learn these offs and ons and the in the
brakes and the gas pedals which is a
different
metal metaphor than drive it's a great
book for all the read together but it's
going to give you common language
and that's what you all need here it
sounds like brother
you have a a heart of safety
a heart of go slow and so what i want to
do is give her some tools and give her
some permission
to don't use the word normal in your
house anymore you got it
yes we're not gonna be normal there's
nothing abnormal about y'all too by the
way
right there's not you're not a normal
guy the heart and compassion you have
for your wife isn't normal
um her being a 49 year old version is
not normal i guess i say not normal it's
not common right that's a better word to
use it's not common
in y'all's decision to love each other
recklessly with abandon and i want every
single 50 year old couple listening to
this show
i want every single 40 year old couple
30 year old couple mid 20s
couple i want you to get into the
mindset of
establishing desire romeo and juliet
lied to you that's not real that was two
tim
teenagers throwing a temper tantrum that
ended up in a murder-suicide thing it
was it's stupid it's not real
what's real is is cultivating desire
cultivating mystery
cultivating a spirit of i refuse
to have anything less than a just
a rambunctious extraordinary sex life
with my husband and my wife
i just don't and so what do we have to
do to get there and first that looks
different for every single couple anyone
who tells you like well you should be
idiots you work it out together y'all
build this together
so jack i love your heart i was gonna
tell them to call me back you don't need
to call me back jack
i'm i'm curious on all of 50 different
levels
don't call me back on this one i love
you and i'm so glad
i got to talk to you today brother all
right so as we wrap up today's show
man we've talked politics we've talked
religion we've talked sex what else have
we talked we've talked at all today man
we've talked james and his just killing
it over here as the uh
producer of the show good job on the
phone number bro all right as we wrap up
today this literally is one of my
favorite songs of all time
and i picked it specifically for today
it's by my favorite rock band that's on
earth
it's a group called social distortion
and their 1996 album white heat white
light white trash
the song is called i was wrong and it
goes like this
when i was young i was so full of fear
and i hid behind anger and held back
tears it was me against the world i was
sure that i'd win
but the world fought back and punished
me for my sins and i felt so alone and
so insecure
but i blamed you instead and made sure i
was heard
and they tried to warn me of my evil
ways but i couldn't hear what they had
to say
i was wrong self-destruction got me
again i was wrong
and i think about my loves i've had a
few i'm sorry that i hurt them that i
hurt you too
i took what i wanted and i put my heart
on a shelf
how can you love me when you don't love
yourself and it's me against the world
and i was sure that i'd win
and they tried to warn me of my evil
ways but i couldn't hear what they had
to say
exhale i was wrong
good folks we've all been wrong we've
all been right we've got to do this
together
this has been the dr john delonay show
[Music]
you